[Applause]
address the fans here at Staples Center
one last time
[Applause]
man guys you know it's uh I can't
believe how fast 20 years went by me
this is crazy this is absolutely crazy
and you know to be standing here at
center court with you guys my team mates
behind me and appreciate knowledge you
know the journey that we've been on you
know we've been through our ups and been
through our downs and I think the most
important point is that we all stayed
together throughout you know I grew up I
grew up a die-hard I mean a die-hard
Laker fan diehard I mean I knew knew
everything about every player that's
ever played here so to be drafted and
then traded to this organization and to
spend 20 years here I mean you can't you
can't write something better than this
and I'm more proud I'm more proud of the
fact that not about the championships
but about the down years because we
didn't run we didn't run we played
through all that stuff when we got our
championships and we did it the right
way and all I can do here is just thank
you guys thank you guys for all the
years of support thank you guys for all
the motivation thank you for the
inspiration
and
you know what's funny the thing that had
me cracking up all night long with the
fact that I go through 20 years of
everybody screaming to pass the bar
during the last night they're like don't
pass it this has been it has been
absolutely beautiful you got I can't
believe it's come to an end you guys
will always be in my heart and I
sincerely sincerely appreciate it no
words can describe how I feel about you
guys and thank you thank you from the
bottom of my heart I got love you guys
and uh
I love you guys
my family - my family my wife Vanessa I
throw it as Natalia Gianna you know
thank you guys for all your sacrifice
you know for all hours I've spent in the
gym working and training vanessa you
hold them down the family the way that
you have I I can't there's no way that I
could thank you enough for that so from
the bottom of my heart thank you and
what can I say my bow
[Applause]
and then the fact that we haven't seen
very many competitors with this type of
passion 24/7 and then the ability to
withstand the pain of all of the
critical injuries that he's had it's
just a marvel that he could come out
here tonight and send every person in
this building home with a major smile on
their face it's great